[Musique]
ce matin l'esprit des morts n'est
descendu à fort-de-france et dès le
premier coup de tambours les enfants ont
déchaîné donne la réplique aux musiciens
ici l'école veut aménager un petit
potager pour les élèves de cp et grande
section et l'esprit du la sotech
expliqué par ses hommes de fond sadni et
parfaitement compris des petits c'est
naturel et projets j'aime la nature la
lâcheté c'est qu'on en trois vaillants
groupé pied on avance au rythme de la
musique
et qu'est ce que ça fait de travailler
en musique bah ça donne tellement bien
ce pour bien l'apprécier
les écoliers sont déjà familiers des
rythmes traditionnels
chaque semaine il danse le ballet dans
le cadre de l'éducation physique et
l'activité du jardin créole vise aussi à
rapprocher les enfants les traditions du
pays
lorsqu'on trouve dans nos jardins
créoles musulmans des concombres des
tomates des gombos des pigments
végétarien est aussi une partie plantes
médicinales alors notre projet à deux
volets un volet jardin créole un volet
embellissement des cobayes d'ivoire on a
un site qui est très grand et très
agréable donc planté des fleurs des
fleurs de chez nous une belle aventure
commence pour ces écoliers qui verront
pousser leurs plantations avec fierté
pour l'association l'esprit la sotech
tout cela a bien sa place à l'école les
mots qu à montreuil au débat gars qui
taille ou qui associe à zhouqu a ouvert
grand grand grand
lespiaucq a ouvert aussi et c'est la
joie non content d'avoir nominé en
licola en morceaux cultes y qui taille
haute ou c'est une bonne chose parce que
ça montre la tradition enfance la nature
donc ils se sont proposés et même
d'aller d'aller labourer les champs et
puis de fond credo remise et
l'association reviendra d'ici là ce sont
les familles qui sont invités à fond
cette nuit samedi prochain 1 la sotech
grandeur nature pour un lieu chez les
autistes gras au morne des cadets